you need to understand them and take
advantage of it you will make trillions
distributed across all of you that is
where to spend your time that is
this is
he likes to frame himself as the
billionaire of the people he's
apparently on the side of retail
investors he wants to spread awareness
about climate change and the pollution
and he wants to change the world for the
better but chamat isn't nothing more
than a master manipulator and a public
relations expert everything he says and
it does is it cynically crafted to draw
your attention and to make you feel a
certain way this is exactly how he was
able to go from being an unknown Rich
douchebag to briefly becoming even more
popular than former retail favorite
Kathy Wood but don't be fooled while
Kathy woodit is getting destroyed by the
market right now she truly believed in
the store believes that every word she
said chamat on the other hand was just
playing the publicity game and he used
his charm and apparent honesty to
attract millions of retail investors
towards him if he had simply construct
directed a fan base it wouldn't have
been a big deal but chameter would
consistently go on to financial news
outlets like CNBC and Bloomberg and spew
investment advice that he himself did
not believe in this would result in
millions of investors to consistently
follow his advice and to get burned
while Thomas would always pull out at
the right time growing his Billion
Dollar Empire now this isn't nothing new
for Wall Street hedge funds and
investment banks are notorious for
screwing over the average investor but
they don't even try to hide it that's
just the game they play they make their
money on the fomo fear and the blunders
of retail investors Thomas on the other
hand likes the Masquerade as the good
guy he's the one that tips a minimum of
100 to support hard-working waiters he's
the one that invests in businesses and
ideas that help build the future for
everyone he's the one who exposes the
phony insiders but in real the only
phone a year is himself so here's the
ugly truth behind the billionaire of the
people
foreign
that people value in someone that they
look up to or take advice from is
authenticity but chamat has virtually no
authenticity because the things he says
have little to do with what he
personally believes in instead he simply
tells you exactly what you want to hear
he cleverly identifies a trending
investment topics and cynically
positions himself squarely on the side
of the retail investor likely one of the
best examples of this positioning is
with Tesla stock by now I'm sure you're
all familiar with the Tesla's insane run
up and eventual crash over the past few
years much of this was caused by retail
investors squeezing out short sellers
who had promoted stock for years so it
was only natural that a sort of
camaraderie and a Brotherhood was formed
amongst these investors they had shown
up hedge funds and even Bill Gates and
now they were gonna huddle till they
can't huddle no more because one screwed
the shorts and the two don't bet against
Elon meanwhile Thomas looking for a way
to get these people behind him and it
turns out this wasn't that hard
virtually everyone on the news other
than Kathy Wood was bagging on Tesla you
see a Slowdown in Model S and XLS and
potential potentially model 3 cells as
that competition enters I think you're
going to get some guys starting to shade
or fade the stock if you will so I think
that's the real Catalyst to get this
stock to fall so all tomato do was
position himself as the billionaire who
supported Tesla all out and that's
exactly what he did I don't understand
why people are so focused on selling
things that work let's just you know
I'll make up a number let's just say I
owned a billion dollars of Tesla stock
if I sold it now I have a billion dollar
problem what do I do with that money the
point is that when things are working
you're paid to stay with people that
know what they're doing and this is a
guy who has consistently been one of the
most important entrepreneurs in the
world and so why bet against him and
that was just one clip Thomas would have
consistently tell the public that they
were essentially a full if they even
thought about selling Tesla Thomas would
even go as far as defending Tesla when
it came to controversial business
decisions hearing on this you would
think that chamat was Tesla's number one
supporter but what if I told you that
tomat would actually end up selling his
entire Tesla stake in fact Chalmette
would end up selling his entire position
within eight months of that clip at
which point he revealed that he had
actually been selling Tesla for nearly a
year this means that he was literally
selling Tesla as he was making that
statement telling everyone to not sell
Tesla looking back someone to play
discards perfectly as this is where he
sold all of his shares well before these
75 percent of Crash but this also means
that this is where many of his followers
bought all of their Tesla shares and
most of them would end up getting
destroyed by this crash when confronted
about his flip-flopping Summit would
simply responded that he has the right
to change his mind but here's what he
forgot to mention when he appears on
these Financial Outlets as the
billionaire investor with authority he
also has the responsibility of leading
investors in the right direction this
doesn't mean that he had to hold on to
his Tesla stake he of course could have
pulled a Cathy wood and hoddled it with
the retailers but he didn't have to as
we discussed he sold it at the perfect
time and unless you're holding on to the
S P 500 you should be willing to switch
your position as a billionaire investor
he knows this so the issue wasn't that
he sold his take the issue was that he
presented Tesla and the andol Biel and
he classified those who sold slot as an
idiot when that may have been the right
choice for many and Tesla is just one
example of his hyperbolic investment
advice he's made similar statements
about Bitcoin Virgin Galactic and a
bunch of other retail favorites as well
heck he even bought calls on GameStop
during the short squeeze but unlike Elon
who truly believed in the effort for
chumez all of these were just publicity
stunts
foreign
making yourself look better by siding
with retailers is one thing but
launching crappy Investments and getting
people to invest is something completely
different as for Thomas well he has done
both Thomas is regarded as the king of
spax but this isn't anything to be proud
of every time you see the word spag you
can replace it with the word scam and it
wouldn't change the meaning all that
much if you're not familiar with specs
it stands for special purpose
acquisition company and it's really just
a scheme to bypass regulation while
making deal sponsors like chamet even
richer here's how it works let's say you
have an up-and-coming company that wants
to go public if you wanted to do it the
right way you would have to go through a
bunch of SEC scrutiny and to pay massive
fees to Simply operate as a public
company you'll have to put out quarterly
reports host shareholder meetings and
probably deal with more audits while
this is truly quite annoying for
businesses these regulations are what
keep retail investors at least somewhat
safe but what if there was a way to work
around this red tape well there is enter
specs specs are basically shell
companies that will go public in place
of the original company people can
invest into this pack and this pack will
turn around and invest into the original
company and given that this pack is just
a shell it's far easier and cheaper to
maintain this pack as a public company
Tom had the likes to frame specs as some
sort of service to retail investors he's
apparently leveling the playing field by
giving Everyday People access to private
Investments but really specs are just a
way to give the public access to highly
volatile private Investments that aren't
quite ready to go public as such these
companies usually get obliterated by the
market once the hype dies down and
that's exactly what happened to
basically all of atomic specs Virgin
Galactic down 94 open door down 97
percent
Clover down at 95 so if I down 85
desktop metal down at 96 proterra down
at 88 latched down at 97 sunlight
Financial down at 94 and a Berkshire
grade down 96 basically every single one
of Thomas facts are down at 90 but none
of this matters for Chalmette because
he's already made his money did you
think that Chum had set up these packs
for free of course not he gets 20 of
every spec he creates for himself and
you can bet that he offloads these turds
as soon as possible for example Thomas
sold his Virgin Galactic stake for over
three times the IPO price which netted
him at 200 million dollars so not only
is Thomas throwing out crappy investment
advice he's literally engineering crappy
Investments that lead to retail
investors losing billions of dollars and
he does all of this while pretending to
be the billionaire of the people
foreign
through all of this you've probably been
wondering why go through all of this
effort to craft a Public Image why not
just be a spacking behind the closed
doors and avoid the Public's eye
altogether well the answer is that
Thomas has political Ambitions of
becoming the governor of California and
all of his public appearances and the
GameStop yolos are his strategy to get
into the good graces of everyday people
but here's the thing if you can't even
trust this guy to hold on to his talk
positions how can you trust him to
execute on his campaign promises the
answer is that you can't and if you
don't yet believe me that chamet is just
a cynical turd just listen to how he
described the euchar genocide in China
and nobody cares about what's happening
to the weakers okay you you bring it up
because you really care and I think it
is the rest of us don't care I'm just
telling you okay you're saying you
virtually don't care I'm telling you a
very hard Ugly Truth okay of all the
things that I care about yes it is below
my line
it's one thing to say that most people
are ignorant of the genocide which is
probably true but and something
completely different to say that people
don't care and that this crime against
humanity is under his line now this is
actually the only time in this video
that I'll actually support tomep I don't
think Thomas actually means what he says
here I think he's trying to use the
Donald Trump and Andrew Tate strategy of
making ludicrous statements just to drop
people's attention for example Trump has
his Infamous line about Mexicans and the
Tate has it dozens of clips about woman
so Thomas may have just been trying to
play into the media cycle and get more
attention for himself but this really
isn't all that much better either tomat
truly does not care about Mass genocide
or he does care and he's cynical enough
to use Master genocide as a publicity
stunt both are just speakable Behavior
just different levels of it fortunately
people didn't fall for his little stunt
and he would end up getting slammed by
his audience and the media alike at the
end of the day though this wasn't the
first time that Thomas had used the
strategy it was just the first time that
he was blasted for it back when he was
promoting Tesla he was literally selling
this talk but he was talking up the
stock just to gain publicity for his
clean energy initiatives as Governor
similarly when he bought into GameStop
he was simultaneously launching specs
that would cost retailers the same
losses that hedge funds were causing but
he had the audacity to act like the
billionaire that was supporting the
strike against Wall Street the reality
is that for chamat everything that he
says and does on TV is just to gain
publicity and momentum for his potential
political career you shouldn't take a
single word he says as his true beliefs
or Genuine advice because in the end he
is just a cynical term foreign foreign
and I would argue that that's well
deserved but we should also note that
chamat is just playing the political
game the reality is that cynicism
backstabbing and the public support are
prerequisites to have any chance of
winning the political game so it's not
really surprising that Thomas has chosen
to play his cards the way that he has
the point of this video however is to
show that we as the somewhat educated
public should also be aware of what game
these people are playing and did not
become overly enthralled in anything
that they say just the biggest torment
likes an investment it doesn't not mean
that you should buy and just because he
talks down on greedy Wall Street doesn't
mean that he won't pull the same tricks
himself it's not personal it's just
business and politics and that's the
truth about chamat palahabatia were you
ever a fan of summit comment that down
below also drop a like if you would like
to see more on mistakes and of course
consider checking out our Discord
Community such as physical video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari I'll see you guys on the
next one
[Music]